hi there steve coffin here
[Music]
uh today i am going to talk about output
talking getting to talking how do we
start talking
uh remember if you enjoy these videos uh
please subscribe you can uh click or tap
on the bell to get notifications
and if you want to learn languages the
way i do please come and join us at link
first of all too i want to say that as
long as the weather is nice i want to
continue doing these videos outside
it's a nice quality of of video
um so
i'm going to talk about getting the
output because i'm in my 90 day
challenge for arabic
and the first month ended i tweeted
about it i've added about 2 400 new
known words to my total of known words
in arabic i've done a lot of reading and
listening but i've also started speaking
more
and so i want to talk a little bit about
speaking and how it you know at least
how i you know integrate that into my
study program
in order i've always said in order to
speak well you have to speak a lot i
don't believe you have to start speaking
early or at any particular time you can
start speaking when you feel like
speaking in my own case i like to start
speaking when i have enough vocabulary
so that i can say a few things even if i
say them incorrectly
and
so that i in a situation where i can
understand what the other person is
saying
now i will put up a video of my
conversation with muhammad from egypt
i think it's about 20 minutes we're
going to put subtitles there for those
of you which is probably the majority
who don't speak arabic and you will see
that i understand him very well
i'm able to say certain things i say
some things incorrectly
he's a very good tutor because he keeps
me talking
and he then sends me a report with my
errors or you know phrases that i had
difficulty with he records these so i
listen to them
from my from experience i'll make the
same mistakes week after week but
gradually get better
but the speaking has a number of
functions first of all
you know obviously when you're just
doing input it's a bit of a lonely
activity you're connecting with
interesting content but you're not
communicating you're not connecting with
anyone and it is a wonderful feeling to
connect with another person in the
language you are learning especially if
it's not stressful you'll see from my
discussion conversation with muhammad
i'm not stressed i struggle to look for
words i know i'm saying things wrong but
it's an enjoyable experience i'm
enjoying the sort of social personal
interaction with muhammad so it kind of
gets me you know in a positive mood
about my arabic second of all it points
out where some of my gaps are things
that i'm struggling with i'm struggling
with the verbs so
with that i made a point of every time i
come across a word in link
i look the verb up
in the uh
reverso
uh conjugator dictionary
because that gives me an overview
because it's very difficult for me to
get used to the way the past tense is
structured in arabic as opposed to the
present tense
uh
i just have to get used to it i'm still
struggling so it's very useful for me
every time i come to a verb review the
different conjugations not try to
remember them but
i know that i have to work on getting my
verbs better
so speaking with the tutor kind of
points out your gaps things that you
need to work on that you need to notice
more
and this then is the third thing i
wanted to talk about
is you know sometimes people think
they're going to talk their way to
fluency i don't think you're going to
talk to talk your way to fluency i think
you have to build up your potential for
fluency through lots of listening and
reading and that's an ongoing thing even
after you start talking you have to
continue doing that broadening your
vocabulary and as we know it becomes
more and more difficult to learn words
because they're more and more they are
low frequency verbs words low frequency
words so it becomes tougher and tougher
to learn them and to remember them so
you have to do a lot of listening and
reading
but the in talking with the uh
and that activity
helps prepare you for speaking
and uh
i you'll see in my conversation with
muhammad
i i think i believe i speak better than
i did
before i started on my 90-day challenge
and
you know i was reminded of of the
importance like we think we're going to
talk our way to fluency it's a bit like
my golf i'm not going to play my way to
becoming a better golfer i've even taken
lessons which only serves to confuse me
but the other day i was on the driving
range and there's a member at our club
who was a
club champion at the club
his name is roy kang he went to some
universe i think arizona state or some
university in the states on a golf
scholarship
and just standing beside him on the
driving range kind of getting that that
sense of how he swings his natural
motion
helped me tremendously just watching him
help me more than deliberate instruction
and you know i am i i don't know if
there's any
you know relationship to this whole
mirror neurons thing where the same part
of our brain is activated when we hear
music
as would be activated if we played that
music let's say on a piano so there is a
lot of sort of things that we learn to
do
that come from our observing them or
hearing them
that not everything necessarily needs to
be learning by doing or learning by
having it explained there's also a lot
of learning through absorbing through
getting the rhythm of something and if
you have a rhythm to the language
through a lot of listening that helps
you when you start to speak but of
course eventually as i've always said to
speak well you have to speak a lot
because you have to also practice
retrieving what you have learned
activating your vocabulary noticing your
mistakes so that you can then
double down
in your listening and reading to notice
more things and then you bring it back
to your conversation so
with that i wanted to talk about getting
to speaking uh have a look at the
interview with with mohammed
i'm going to do another one in a month
and my main activity of course is
listening and reading but increasingly
i'm going to be speaking
uh
and
hopefully uh i will improve but my main
goal again
is is is not necessarily the speaking i
would like to see my speaking ability
improve but i want to understand these
podcasts from al jazeera because if i
can just pick them up in the morning and
listen to them and understand 70 or 80
percent i know that is going to
influence my speaking ability it's going
to make my
my uh use of the language more natural
so that then i have this this base this
potential that i can really develop in
my in my interactions uh with with
muhammad because after all it's only
going to be a few hours a week so it's
not as if i'm living in egypt and can
speak every day for hours so there you
have it
my take on getting to speaking look
forward to your comments bye for now
[Music]